[Musique]
caroline en a ras-le-bol de l'hiver elle
s'achète un billet d'avion en ligne pour
le mexique
le jour du départ tout excité mais où
comtois l'agent lui refuse
l'embarquement
caroline a fait une faute de frappe dans
son prénom les informations sur son
passeport et sur son billet d'avion ne
sont pas identiques lui refuser
l'embarquement pour ça c'est sûr non
c'est la loi et transports canada
l'afrique à la lettre pour des raisons
de sécurité le transporteur doit
s'assurer de l'exactitude des noms sur
le billet et le passeport
sinon ils paient une amende fautes de
frappe non l'inversé
la moindre erreur va clouer au sol
dommage parce que caroline aurait pu
corriger les informations sur le piège
des chroniques mais généralement cette
correction doit être fait plusieurs
jours avant le départ si elle veut
partir aujourd'hui elle doit acheter un
billet gros prix le fin mot de
l'histoire qu'une simple fond et vous
pensez du beau voyage au banc de neige